the Philippine government has lost its
second attempt to stop the international
criminal court from investigating the
so-called War on Drugs as a tribunal's
appeals chamber voted to resume the
investigation into the controversial
Crackdown ordered by former president
Rodrigo duterte we tip the skills in our
favor would be the almost 100 support of
victims so the ICC is a victim-centered
court victims such as Jane Lee's husband
Michael who witnesses say was shot by
masked men in 2017. she says she's lost
her faith in the criminal justice system
years but the police never got back to
me with any updates on their
investigation
police records show more than six
thousand were killed during drug raids
since 2016. but human rights
organizations estimate thousands more
were killed vigilante Style
since then there have been only two
murder convictions of policemen
families of victims a former president
Rodrigo duterte's Drug War as
celebrating the decision of the
international criminal court to resume
its investigation into extrajudicial
killings but it is a cautious
celebration president Ferdinand Marcus
Jr and his officials have said they are
not cooperating with the ICC
it is of course the Philippine
government had argued that it is taking
steps to seek Justice for victims and
that it had withdrawn from ICC
jurisdiction in 2019.
the crimes committed again in the
Philippines uh were in the Philippines
was still a member of the Rome statute
which is a treaty that created ICC are
still going to be uh under the
jurisdiction of the ICC for
investigation
families of victims and their supporters
say they're under No Illusion that
Justice will now be handed to them but
every small step towards Justice they
say matters
below Al Jazeera Manila
Donald Trump says he's received